it's a pleasure
and indeed an honor to welcome
dr. Andrea Titus to Yale today to speak
here about European memories from the
gulag to the Commission and those of you
who know his life know that that in fact
describes a very long path is taken and
that began in Soviet gulag dr. Andrew
and I'm using the word doctor because as
many of you know he is a doctor he's a
heart surgeon and or was and his family
was deported from Lithuania in 1941
about a hundred and thirty thousand
Lithuanians were deported to labor camps
and about another hundred and fifty
thousand were deported to prison camps
to the gulags and his parents were
deported he was actually born in the
USSR some years after they arrived it
wasn't until several years after the
death of Stalin in 1953 that the
deportees were allowed to return
and it's he and his family returned to
Lithuania in 1958 I believe and he
studied in Lithuania studied medicine in
Lithuania was arrested by the KGB in
Lithuania but what is one of the major
events in his life was I would say the
late years of Gorbachev perestroika and
the development of the Lithuanian reform
movement salutis in the 1980s and 88 and
he was he was involved in that he was a
member he was elected to the Supreme
Soviet
when Lithuania still had a Supreme
Soviet in 1990 in the first contested
elections as a member and those of you
who are old enough to remember that
election you'll remember was a cellulous
landslide and he became one of the
leaders and founders of the Lithuanian
Social Democratic Party was and when
Lithuania gained its independence he was
deeply involved both in writing the act
of Independence and writing the
constitution of Lithuania continuing to
serve and the new Lithuanian Parliament
he was reelected in 1996 and again in
2002
head of the chair of the Lithuanian
Social Democratic Party
I became at one point in 2001 the deputy
deputy speaker or Deputy Chair of the
Parliament and this was a time as as you
recall when Lithuania like Estonian
Latvian other countries was involved in
the European integration process moving
toward membership and he chaired the
European integration program in
Parliament in those years he was elected
again to the Parliament in 2008 and
re-elected in 2012 and became a Minister
of Health in the Lithuanian government
and then in 2014 he became the
Commissioner for health and food safety
of the European Union so it is an
extraordinary life and career unlike I
think anyone else we've had speak here
in the range of events from a gulag and
the Soviet Union in the really bad dark
days to the Commission of the European
Union so it's a real pleasure to have
you here and with us today and I also
want to introduce Brad Woodward who is a
professor of history at the University
of New Haven and is the director of the
Baltic Studies program here in the
Macmillan Center and someone who has
written extensively about the Baltic
countries and is going to have a
discussion
with dr. Andrew Qaeda it's about some of
these really historic events that he
experienced firsthand so without further
ado I'll turn it the mic I guess I don't
need to turn the microphone over you
have a microphone president country
first time in our history and I take
today European Union and it's very
important it's very symbolic you know
first of all and it's also very
important that that that when we were
members of European Convention 2002-2003
building so-called charity establishing
constitution for Europe then we proposed
to introduce in in treaty rule that
countries should president should rotate
in presidency rotate on equal footing
this was our proposal and now I am very
happy that equal footing allow the
president's country and now we are here
for me it's unbelievable in Bandra here
gentlemen thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you thank you both very much and
thank you very much for coming to be
with us here at Yale so if you if you
followed this biography it's it's beyond
astounding you have lived numerous lives
a life and deportation a life in in in
those decades of the Soviet Union from
the late 50s into the into the 1990s a
time that people thought in in the
Soviet Union in here that might not ever
end and then all of a sudden does
perestroika the independence movement
the resistance movement within the
Soviet Union of which you were a part
and then all of the events since the
early 90s with with independence it's
it's it's astounding how do you keep
track of all of those different selves
within you all of those different people
I don't know
now looking back you see maybe it was
something something as as you know I
determined but I don't believe in
determinations you know for my point of
view it's my story's not it's you can
see a lot of people this is the same
story I remember and that because you
mentioned that you are from from Estonia
enterto and and also also some
dissidents from from Latvia
I remember our meetings in 1972 in 1978
discussing some issues you know you may
remember memorandum of 745 dissidents of
Baltic States which was signed in 1978
asking United Nations to discuss issues
about occupation of a Baltic state and
it was signed by dissidents from Estonia
Latvia and Lithuania of course I am
proud that one of the distance was my
father who signed such such memorandum
and and and at and at that time no it
was like like like you know like like
strong believes that something really
happened and and such like you know I
can't explain why but feeling that
something will happen and those messages
about freedom will be translated into
reality
let's follows all all my life also and
today it's very difficult very difficult
to explain how it was but but it was you
know I can't explain from from my point
of view it's it's it's part of my life
you know I can't separate and can't
explain I can't tell what was happened
but but but but dedication to Toto to
independence the freedom it was from I
remember my childhood days in in Polar
Circle I was bought the laptop see in
Arctic Ocean and it's gulags were built
and then terrible situation and of
course for me was nothing terrible
because I was child I do not saw
different world and was for me all
things were okay because I have mother
father brothers and and of course
international environment Estonians
Latvians Kerala fence Ukrainians
Russians cousins you remember that
period of also was five yes Wendy Wendy
Wendy lager was destroyed I was five
years remember it's very simple you know
barracks barracks barracks and then
turned round
nothing nothing your parents had been
there already ten years my parents were
deported they were arrested in 1944 one
on 30th of June many deportation
deported first of all they were deported
into Altai and in 1941
in in period of war standard
administration decided that they should
exploit fish in laptop sea because those
seas were occupied Baltic Sea and and
and and and black sea and they of course
from the eastern part Japan and they
decided to talk to to cultivate Arctic
Ocean and that started to build loggers
and my parents were arrested a second
time in Altai and were imprisoned in -
included gulags and from 1941 to 90/55
they spend life in terrible conditions
of course I can't compare their life
this just me because you know their
experience their strong you must have
had amazing parents you follow those
stories of people with those experiences
and how they managed to come back and
and maintain his feelings so yes you are
right because they have I have all my
life in Soviet Union I have status space
space distress blast per person status I
have no chance to move outside and and
why I was always under supervision of
KGB it was I know that that we receive
space displaced persons in 1954 and then
such space Spets displaced persons
status allow us to go from Arctic Ocean
to southern part of Yakutia but such
status was always till 1990 my last you
know my my last characteristics of my my
KGB file was done in 1990 on 11th of
March and I have such when they
proclaimed our independence you know
it's it means but it helps to develop
you know sort of stands against such a
regime and stand so and and and so you
and your family are back in Lithuania
and then you you obviously excelled at
school you because you you brought
yourself to medical
yes first of all you know you know that
inside at the time it was obligatory
Toto to go to school because it was
obligatory location and I'm very happy
it helps me a lot to achieve and but I I
do not belong to no one at ideological
organization you know at that time we
have children organization is called
October October Attis October October
children and then pioneers and then
comes the month I not belong to you
remember that you may remember those
decisions and because there was pressure
to yeah long even in areas that were not
part of Russia proper of course it was
it was it was not so easy
first of all then that was in child you
know my father this told to teachers no
and I was proud and teachers do not do
not press me but then it was I was in in
first class then why didn't they ask me
to taller I said no and that comes from
Oh once again now because it was not so
easy but doesn't matter it's my history
and and of course also it was very
important retort to have highest good
results in education because you can't
imagine in Soviet Union was competition
between between different organizations
you know some some red red flux which
were donated to those who are who
achieved better results and in class you
know all all children all children
consumed all are you a one not but but
my achievements were absolutely on the
highest level
it was very proud showing that we have
ok complete in our knowledge at the same
level
it's multivator total to show that yes
positive approach entities and as you
pushed in academic achievement then go
into medical medical school those
pressures from the state would not have
ceased in fact they would have got they
must have intensified in strength yes
you know not yes if not first of all you
can understand that if if I decide to go
to study law it will be forbidden knows
of your state's designee if I will go to
study submit attorney it will be
forbidden and if I will go to
pedagogical issues it will be for me
closed or or they they do not allow me
to but then I came to a medicines that
was of course open now and only one
thing to be prettier to defend your
positions knowledge achievements and so
on and and to be capable to show your
capacity stone and of course I was an
under under supervision of course in
student time I started to organize
underground movement we established some
small students organization in 1972 such
a regulation was from maybe fifteen
people of course they discovered I was
arrested once again but they do not
touch me because it was not enough in a
fact because we explained as our
cultural activities and nothing more and
after after finishing college medical
incident I was arrested in 1976 on 17th
of September was my first and we were
already in a medical internship at that
period yes of course but but it was
first time but back in but they allowed
to meet to the practices and practices
all my time and of course I was in some
the
a restricted area but it helped me
helped me to develop my my practical
skills and if you don't need to stay
more or less high on on professional
level and they know that my professional
achievements were very well accepted by
people I have a lot of good good results
and it helped me also to continue my
ideas to develop my second ground I
decided to study history I don't know
who can help me translate ja Devillier
how Canton okay how can I translate what
they accused in the studios III didn't
decided to study history
why because I have a ideas you know
first of all I love love very much my
colleagues from previous time who will
fight us on independence a lot of
medical doctors starting this winces
Paducah finishing various with the
doctor cassis greenness they were my you
know my ideas and and and I try to do
the same and of course I decided to go
into deeper studies of history being
also medical doctor history and being
prepared myself to confront publicly
confront with Soviet system and of
course then it will be much you know
much strongest voice of you know of
you know thou prepared you know fighter
and it helped me Toto could you say a
little bit more about the motivation of
people in the anti-soviet movement so by
by this time in the 1970s the the
military anti-soviet movement which had
existed from after the war into the
nineteen into the 1950s so this is
Forest Brothers right people who have
found refuge in the forest and during
the daytime it will come out at night
they were they were found and eliminated
by by the by the late 1950s and so this
is a new kind of resistance how well
could you talk about though the the
motivation of this new Civic kind of
resistance and and it's a it's a fairly
small number of people still yes it
still was quite small number of people's
you know personally when I was involved
in in network of dissidents I have more
114 hundred twenty addresses with those
people with whom I communicated that's
all in the tinea in Latvia Estonia it
was less it was less about 40 about 20
in Estonia I know some of them
personally killed to those days and and
then we went a generation which was from
those who returned back from from gulags
mainly and those who would who kept on
her own positions Toto to continue the
resistance and to teach their children
to stay in the same position and and and
it helps us to developed our our new
approaches new skills and of course also
situation wasn't changes as you know you
remember 1960
Prague Spring this was my mouth time I
was in last in level of last last stages
of my my school school and and such
Alexander Dubcek and Czech
czechoslovakians communists for us they
create hope about social lives with
human face not about Soviets not about
about Stalinists about about Peres
nervous but about absolutely different
approach and also you know it was
important to to to have some information
from Moscow from those days Leningrad
from those dissidents who presented a
lot information about about issues in in
so-called socialist camp or which way
and and it helps us to to to to to go
into some to the next stage of of
understanding that we need to build
cultural resistance intellectual
resistance so-called dissident movement
and to keep it high I adapt to show such
profile in society to create some
informal networks and of course and to
and to develop new new psychological
behavior which will be which was
different from from official and and but
but frankly speaking connection with
those who were deported and were
[Music]
oppressed was connection was but but
style was absolutely different the going
in supposed to those who were born in
yes and our our what style was different
to understanding that we need to to
prepare ourselves to be strong and to be
much educated to be much advanced to be
much progressive to or post
communists no it was very important to a
post communist publicly in our meetings
and they were in difficulties when I use
a same language the same theoretical
formulas quoting Marx and and and and
confusing them
and of course and and and especially it
was very dangerous they they you know
they have some so-called hours of
ideological say awareness and those
hours we confront is very very very
strong and of course using the same you
know the articles from from Karl Marx or
from treat the youngest not from Lenin
from from Stalin
it is absolutely publicly know that it
confused it confuse very much I have a
lot of meetings publicly debating that
of course you know that KGB called me
called me a revisionist nationalist okay
it means okay revision is you know I
belong to those Mensheviks which were
killed in Stalin type and I am very
proud today that today they really
described my my my ideas yes I was it
was a non democratic side of socialism
not on nationalism but but but for them
it was very very dangerous to have those
who can oppose arguing about the same
issues from different angle when we
started to discuss for example about
democracy and socialism I remember very
well I told them I quote but Bertrand
Russell that it is you know because
mattresses was allowed as as philosopher
and so I called look but the thought is
this better death be death like like
your type of socialist and always
immediately confused around and I
explained you know if you are real
progressive you should understand
problems is imposed
without democracy when they arrested me
and Saturday in total to investigate the
doctor to talk to you know Turk
questioned me they asked about what are
you thinking I told them very simple you
know what I told him
so I can tell it in Russia and then
translate into into English I told Zee
say use Soviet skills lessons teach
skills public KGB officers also know
about whatever look there
it means yes and no you have the right
to be yes or no it means democracy ok
Union it means Union on equal footing on
possibilities be in Union or go out of
Union Soviet it means that you should
promote that power should be enhance of
democratically elected service not on of
those who who also painted powers and
and introduced dictatorship and respond
respond it means less popular countries
democratic elections you know I feel a
grievous concept of our service Union
let's do it on a normal democratic of
grounds once again you know they they
they were very confused with my
arguments but is it reality so then in
1985 the Soviet Union gets a new leader
1985 we have 9 1985 Mikhail Gorbachev
comes to power it's several years before
this movement of allowing a a
restructuring a perestroika of society
happens but by 1987 things are very
different in all three Baltic republics
the movement which had been small now
can be joined by many people who hope to
voice dissatisfaction how did that how
did I'm sure you remember those those
years 1987 88 I remember those yes in
exactly in
in hours minutes seconds days nice buns
because because it was really speaking
of nation others feeling when spring and
of course also I can tell you
Estonians were leading in this position
Estonians my friend marked tarmac he was
very active in building Estonian front
and we have a relationship you know
business with Estonian of course in
detainee you can see new generation
which were not far from dissident
movement but they were under influence
of of of a free environment which was
around because you know nobody can close
doors I'm not allowing people to
understand what is in Finland in Sweden
and in Poland polish processes were very
powerful so the darkness that was very
you know so so so big influence and
Estonians they started to be the first
and it's great good opportunity that
something should be done in latina but
in our circles in dissident circles we
were very worried about possibility to
be in front
why because nobody knows how will react
Moscow in in this situation and we
started to influence more official and
you know communist consume all more
official but but very known persons like
you seen as medicine carriages are with
the society stromwell the socialist
doesn't met a lot and it helps helps to
joint forces dissidents were a little
bit on the bench
and those who started to oppose publicly
or prom-prom proposed perestroika from
the beginning it was movement in favor
of support Gorbachev P destroyed and
then then the we started to build
network between those who knows much
more about history and those who were
involved because of garbage oak or
garbage or perestroika open new
perspectives and and and and of course
it's takes time
there's no tasting water in the DNA
first activity was organized by little
and freedom movement a last that was
Lazarus League and Tanis telescas was
was the first he was the prisoner he was
dissident he was very prominent very
strong but such movement was very very
small and when so-called officials
joined the restaurant and the ideas and
then you you can't imagine as as brown
movement that all things were changing
in in hours hours and hours and of
course and we decided to manifest eight
and to raise political slogans and
organized parties can you imagine it
started to organize parties in 1988 in
888 in Supreme Soviet Union like it's
called sheis de patata you know at that
time from the tinea where the Congress
of Deputies were three Social Democrats
the 1984 God was a joke you know they
didn't never take it seriously but we
started to organize also multi-party
system design Zionist movement and it
was successful
it was very and culturally as well this
was a springtime of people's there are
song festivals other forms of literature
other forms of of the Arts started to
flourish a a return to something that
had existed in the past right there's no
could now flourish again clearly was
palpable I I first came to the Baltic
region
in 1990 I was born in this country and I
this was this was it was an amazing
feeling the most the most the strong
sense of optimism even though this was
still happening within the state of the
Soviet Union then Lithuania starts
playing a leading role in 1990
politically but widely and I started to
play a leading role first of all we
should bear in mind different situation
it was demography absolutely the
question in Estonia you know very well
it was 49 percent of Estonians 51
percent of russian-speaking
in Latvia it was more or less 50 50 in
Lithuania they have only 12 percent of
russian-speaking it was for much more
easier and and and of course we have not
we have you know and of course also
please bear in mind that cultural
activities in period of of Soviet time
from 1966 1980s were very closed in
cooperation between us Latvia Lithuania
Estonia song festival sportive and
students exchanges and and all knows in
Soviet Union that three Baltic states is
west of the Union in people mind is not
the same it was west of the Union
something west and we were proud that
that you know that a lot of young people
were very proud that we are known Soviet
West Soviet West
yes it was Soviet yes all right and of
course also you can imagine when sport
events and play our now our basketball
teams
Zalgiris against CSKA it means who
creates a lot of what of often of you of
the emotions of a proud or tampo caliph
or now as it's absolute column
it means god of you know it is a hero
national heroes vulgaris is better which
is own evil and this creates proud of
nationality and such feeling that we are
closer we are something west of course
all the gene
has memory about about occupation about
first period of Independence but
generation youngest who also has
feelings that this I said they treated
by a Soviet they tilted a little bit
different and it helps a lot to atone
and of course is with this fermentation
you know what was well it was very quick
in in period of 1987 and 1990 1990 and
it helps a lot at auto to understand
each other and to build networks and
have networks different organizations
and and of course Lilliana because of
demographic situation so could you talk
a little bit about 1991 it's in January
of that year when if there was a period
where there was great fear that all of
this westernization and all these
changes might be turned back seemed like
a possibility in January of 1991 yes I
was I was in those events no I was under
an attack of Soviet troops I was in
front of our radio committee not in not
closer to tower to give it our but but
but which was in my eyes but what I can
tell you unity of nation was so high so
high you can't imagine no fear no
absolutely fear and its despite the
Spetsnaz this just despite despite and
despite not only Spetsnaz
can you imagine tanks tanks are going
tank and people are staying around and
blocking and saying stop tanks and that
and soldiers are absolutely contingent
in confusion because so design shock
nobody knows what can they do our people
are singing around tanks this is such
and such feelings that okay it is our
our time
it's our glory and it is our victory
feeling was like that and you can see
millions of millions of people millions
all to me to two and a half millions
where the series and of course the same
speaking about in Latvian and in Estonia
and can you imagine that it was good
feeling than in Moscow in Leningrad in
Kiev in big demonstrations were in
support and such ties between democratic
Russia and people who started to think
that it is something has happened and
never again return into stalinistic time
it was very common in big big every of
Soviet Union you how can you explain
demonstrations in hundreds of thousands
of people demonstrations in Kiev in in
Moscow in Leningrad its fact is reality
because feeling was at sea is that they
should fight against those Bolsheviks or
Stalinist or Brezhnev East and never
turn such life in back and his jobs a
lot as he absolutely no means no fear on
the streets it is I I you know it's as
excellent is picture when people are
pushing back tank with hands such
picture should be disseminated in around
the globe like possibilities to fight in
peaceful way against all military
aggressions it's symbolic which and
people were willing to push back with
their boats as well and March refer in
in in in all three countries referenda
helm yes yes of course that and then the
end so and then to organize referendum
was so easy because you know yeah
absolutely we've been in in in in
in no doubt this vision visual rules are
following the rules and procedures it
was not not difficult to argue that
people let's come and vote in every
family it was a and in your three Baltic
states after those events it helps us to
once again to take second breath and go
forward you know it saw something out of
the Union yeah and and then Union
collapse and imagine how what is feeling
was in time of push announced in August
August 1981 yes August and it was
immediately a feeling was yes finally
finally we achieve and I remember such
the periods of life like brilliant
periods of millions of positive people
and you know so then you have a new
career or at least a continued well a
Aiden a continuation and yet in new
environment in an independent in a
sovereign state so how did that how what
was that like in the 1990s and into the
early 2000s a very different environment
of course of course and then of course
you know after after some big emotional
unity then came time of difficult I
liked very much you know sorta to say
because I am here in other states but I
am I was opponent so called concept of
constructive destruction solar friends
such constructive destruction was on
shoulders of ordinary people so painful
period of so-called reforms
privatization crash of social standards
clash was it was and of course then you
can see how it was for me it's very
painful now at a remembrance I remember
very well a period of unity of nation
and then
fragmentation of society and touch for
argumentation was very painful [ __ ] and
of course then we started to rebuild
once again positive approaches the
crisis economic crisis was very deep
standards life standards goes down you
know it's what it really was very very
difficult period between 1993 and 1997
more or less more or less we started
Toto to go and of course then the hope
was main hope was to join European Union
main hope there was people millions of
people decided yes only one way if we
can join and achieve support structural
support of Union and of course to
develop once again to restore our living
standards and it was it was second
breath of pasta to be active and to eat
or to totem to the go into more or less
socially oriented market economy of the
jungles of of privatization and to go
into and it creates a lot of big support
to joining EU and of course also joining
NATO but NATO joining this was much less
people were less worried about they were
much more worried about their living
standards and EU was as as understanding
but ok it will be our future and you can
see unity once again Estonia Latvia T
and we spent a lot of time in Baltic
assembly I was I am founding father of
Baltic as one of hundreds of Baltic
salmon and a lot of difficult debates
between between us intentions and
different views first of all then we
started to compete who will be the first
or maybe the one the first will be
you know invited into EU then he will
take second - no no let's go together
and it was Oh brilliant
time of different different
[Laughter]
possibilities and of course and finally
we decided now it will be better once
again to stay united and to achieve EU
and on the same pace and but but but of
course you and NATO those two factors
can once again restore feeling of a
button because of crisis between 1992
and 1997 was very difficult so beginning
in 2004 then things look a little bit
different I we're getting a little bit
closer a little bit closer to the
present you see there are so many lives
here they doctor and a Turkish as lead
and we could we could talk about that
but I'm also sensitive to the fact that
there are a number of people here each
with isn't his or her own concern some
of them may be about Lithuania some of
them may be about the EU some of them
may be about European wide issues so
maybe at this point we could turn to
questions if you have a question please
raise your hand and we can have passed
you the microphone and maybe you could
just identify yourself briefly at the
beginning could we go to you're sensing
the problems of time what languages
people need to ask but not not because
it's enough tonight I'll start off and
ask a question about relating to the EU
and your marvelous life story goes up to
the time of the EU but you've played an
important role in EU something many
people probably don't know is that you
were actually involved even before
Lithuania joined officially in the
negotiation
of the treaty establishing a
constitution for Europe the 2002-2004
project that failed in a referendum in
France and the Netherlands but then was
revived in slimmed down downsized
version in the Treaty of Lisbon and then
lo and behold several years later you're
a member of the European Commission and
and I wondered if you could say
something about your your experience as
a member of the College of Commissioners
in in the EU both representing Lithuania
but now also representing as
commissioners do the EU as a whole
openly I will tell you I am very happy
that I'm commissioning now why because
it's a very difficult period for Union
ireally Union is in crossroads and then
they came into Commission 2014 we faced
immediate crisis which was you know
first of all we have five five countries
Ireland Portugal Spain Italy Greece and
it was grexit you remember I was so
difficult in event Cameron decided to
play game just telling that he can ask
us how to strengthen you proposing
proposals which are vacancies not
strength and with women's were strange
but they proposed to change wording that
ever closer Union in Lisbon treaty to
delete ever closer Union you know who
proposed such wording ever closer Union
in treaty establishing constitution for
Europe it was British conservatives only
after inserting ever closer Union I have
a joke ever closer Lunia Union it means
distance between
English Channel you know ever closer
Union British channel and it's always
close and constantly you know but but it
is but it was they proposed and then
come and started to argue that it should
be deleted because it's very bad it was
a real example of hypocrisy okay
started to play a game until one hand
grexit like you know like some judge
nervous started to call it in another
what can we do with with with with with
Cameron's proposals and in thought big
big crisis in five countries and is
immediately after it was started of the
serious crisis big flow of often of
refugees and migrants and the Europe was
in in in you know in turbulence but we
are proud I am very proud about Jean
Claude Jean Claude he is very clever of
course maybe not so visible but he's
very clever experienced guy really he
calls me in college mr. Bullock
I am proud about that always mister good
luck what is your opinion okay that's
advice and and it it really shows that
we spent a lot of time dealing this very
tough challenges first of all we decided
to do our best
helping Greece to not to go out of
eurozone because it will be
repercussions aversive is difficult and
it takes a lot of efforts a lot of and
then second immediately we started to
discuss with Cameron what can we do
which wording will be more acceptable to
to to propose that he really improved
and British referendum nobody accepted
Jesus you know all thought about more or
less optimistic scenario 53 47 54 45 52
but nobody expect that will be it will
be opposite of course UK society now is
in deep divide we all know that and
results were shocking
and after we started to manage
situations turkey in their internal
Turkish issues a very complicated one
and possibly related to total to
navigate how can we achieve agreement
controlling flow of and flow of
smugglers because not it's not about
refugees it's about smugglers is about
illegal illegal migrants it is a main
mode challenge which should be addressed
and you know I am very proud that we
were on the ground we have a lot a lot
of experience dealing with very
difficult using in lesbos Island in in
everyone and finally crisis with visa
vis with Maidan and crisis and in Crimea
it was a bunch again and of course no
Isis attacks within the European Union
can you imagine our mandate we are very
proud that in our mandate we have a lot
of challenges look and we survived we
survived and we we presented to people
that yes European Union model is vital
and but it's not it's not it's not easy
every day is difficult job day and night
and and of course you look at economic
growth more or less more or less
economic stabilization 2008 economic
crisis affects a lot of people lives why
not well today they have people
following some you know some more
radical more more populistic approaches
Italy or Hungary or or Poland because of
of people lost a lot of a lot of of
feeling that has secured their living
standards are more or less you know 55
million people are empowered in European
Union it's not so you know not so simple
picture and how can we restore trust in
European project and now it is vital
question how can we restore trust in
European model because it's not so it's
not not not easy task and and and and I
think experience which has helped us to
act with different challenges I am very
proud that we have a lot of experienced
people in our in our team because all
our prime ministers or ministers or you
know commissioners second time it helps
us to Toto to create team-building
approach when talk a special that we are
am proud that we survive and now it's
positive possibilities and positive
message because now we have very
important relationship with United
States administration modernist
yeah in in in in in in the way to to to
to find behavior you know to behave okay
but that's it but frankly speaking I
think that that this this commission was
and the big and the big you know
pressing off of very big difficulties
and once again we approved European
Union model as capable model as capable
for my point of view it is it is unique
yes I am proud of this union of course
if you compare constantly treaty
establishing constitution for Europe
mechanism with Lisbon Treaty Lisbon
Treaty mechanism Rica compared to to
those mechanism which were proposed by
by convention and it is it's a pity but
European if if we will this we will be
successful adapting if it would be
successful adapting such constitutional
treaty European Union today would be
much stronger but I am optimistic sorry
I thank you so much for the wonderful
talk so my question has two parts to it
one of them is you talked a lot about
the unity of the nation and the
fragmentation of that Union after the
collapse so do you think that was
because we lost an external enemy and
then the second part of the question how
United do you think with way ta is now
and what are some of the biggest
challenges
now I think that such external enemy yes
from from United States point of view
you have external enemy because it was a
period of Cold War we were inside and
inside I have not external enemies I
have the number of big friends between
Russians Ukrainians latvian estonian
scousers it is for me painful today to
say that i lost a lot of friends
- it's very painful process but we don't
really know in in in time of January
events Moscow Democrats still avoid the
reference we have no understanding that
we will be enemies
we know that enemies were different but
not not people on the streets and now
today between a number of ordinary
people you know the memory that they
have golden time when they were friends
is remain but fragmentation has social
and economic factor this is the main
question because crisis and shock
therapy was very painful experiment I
sometimes I am joking because I compare
communists with those who proposed
destructive constructive destruction
because are in both in both cases you
can do experiments with people lives
sorry it will be better to do
experiments with animals not with people
lives okay doesn't matter he said it's
about joke but reality was that crisis
was very difficult for people and it was
a fragmentation and now now today you
know fragmentation has different also
composition you know now we do not have
industrial society you young generation
now absolutely different compared to us
we who remember trade unions
actors in their own absolutely different
now you are working on on temporary you
know agreements three jobs per day
computers and so no uber and vaisakhi
and and it's it's individualization of
younger generation is it is very visible
and solidarity is also very important
feeling and my generation was in a big
crash because post-industrial situation
deep crisis and fragmentation has
economic aspects and not not about about
possibility understand that it enemy of
course what is painful for me that cold
war and it but language of cold war
continue to exist and it is for me a
little bit strange because it will be
better to create new language and new
options and to see how can we create
know our relationship based and
multilateralism and based on on
different different new possibilities
going out of oldest understanding going
out of of Cold War because it is it it
is way nothing you know rightly
mentioned some some some my friends
mention that you know walls never
replace bridges walls have different you
know meaning than bridges it is better
to build bridges of course it is
difficult and now but I believe that we
can build new bridges despite today's
some slogans someone country should be
first I don't know which country should
be first for me it's not not not not
I have no not big interest about be
first before me it will be much
interesting
see solidarity and planet development of
planet in more consistent more
sustainable way and sustainability
require new mechanisms and it's time to
rethink our our you know I'm sorry are
you applying that that metaphor of the
the bridges eastward as in addition to
westward right now it does feel like at
least in this country that there's a new
cold war with us with with Russia yes I
feel that it would be better to build
bridges German nuclear Wars and
personally I am very happy that you pian
European Union approach they have now to
introduce sanctions one point second to
ask follow Minsk agreements to implement
Minsk agreements for all sides thought
to have selective engagement because we
have questions where we need to have
real pragmatism and forced to build
tiles people-to-people it it is very
important to build ties within people
and people believe me for me it's better
to build bridges between people between
scientists between doctors between
students with Ian to build to go out of
language of wars it's better to build
peace than world for my point of view is
very simple but also it's difficult to
achieve I know that these four questions
thank you for a wonderful presentation I
just want to tell you that in 91
after the porch in Moscow where I was
four days after 19 the pooch I was in
the Baltic countries as a librarian
going from Estonia Latvia Lithuania and
I witnessed a lot of excitement and I
saw national libraries in life in
Lithuania turned into medical first a
Punk'd to take care of wounded who were
just attacked by hormones and so forth
anyway I built a lot of regenerative no
no I was there after August puch it was
late and then the main issue when I was
elite when I was is the what is Bush
doing is he going to recognize latreille
Nia as an independent state and as I was
leaving on the 3rd of September I heard
the news yes he did recognize it but I
had the honour of being an American
there before that and everybody was
wonderful to me and I have great
memories but I have a question security
question I just came back from Croatia
and the president of Croatia Kalinda
Qatar which is talking a lot about three
C's Union like Baltic Sea Black Sea
Adriatic seas and countries around these
seas sort of a cooperation Economic
Cooperation security cooperation and so
forth it's pretty popular idea in
Croatia but I would like to hear from
you is this also popular in Lithuania
and in other Baltic countries regional
cooperation is not only because of
regions but because European Union
policies they have five big so-called
original regional
corporal technically Danube region
Mediterranean Baltic region and Central
European and Paran enrich why because it
is bad you know it because it is very
practical
I was very practical so to to if you
look at possibilities so to build
networks between electricity grids it's
very practical
off if you see possibilities to develop
roads and and and and and of course
build some green power stations of
course also it's very very good
instrument to encourage regional
governments cooperate in the same way
using structural funds in most energetic
way planning together because if you are
planning infrastructure
you should understand you need if one
country will build in this way another
Ananas that you never can achieve
effectiveness because it rigged up
interconnection and regionalization is
very practical idea and speaking about
about about you know feeling all
countries feel that they have the
national identity and it is ok it's ok
it every country national identities
asset European Union from a portfolio I
can tell you very simple when I am going
to to member states I ask which foot is
the best Italian ours Hungarian ours
lieutenant ours all countries I defend
until they proclaim the abroad used the
best foot it means generally we have
European Union best food in the world
yes thank you this is so close to people
heart I see a little bit
you know strange feelings anthem people
confronted national identity with
European you know feeling Co Philippine
solidarity if you are playing game as
nationalist is different one think of
your playing as protectionist you know
below have difficult discussions with
Polish government with with Hungarians
we have enough difficulties now with
Italy because if you know is they should
understand that that that they should at
the sense that they are not alone that
they have regional cooperation for
example in Italy you can listen that
they already defend tell that Italians
farmers my question is are you ready to
defend Croatian farmers because it's not
so far yes in in different set of
Adriatic Sea or Slovenia so what are you
thinking about only Italian food but but
but but and I am playing game a little
bit with those guys who are using such
such language but but a generalization
of some real project is very very very
very good very very workable but of
course it's not inconvenient
confrontation with possibilities of
common pan-european border guard because
we know that it will be English and of
course also the original really can help
us achieve more solidarity because then
people understand ok if am in solidarity
with Estonians Latvians it means that it
is natural but how can I be solidarity
with Greece Greece is so far from from
little understanding but if you can
develop solidarity feeling between three
three or four at regional level it helps
us to talk to you know to build more
ties between different actors I do not I
do not see
dangerous in situation you've been now
for years or nearly nearly four years as
the Commissioner for health and food
safety you can you speak a little bit
more about the accomplishments over that
that you've seen over the last four
years about accomplishments well or the
the maybe about fraud food fraud
let's go directly food fraud okay or or
you know double standards in in in dual
quality and who attends the world yes we
are not living in ideal world absolutely
and and of course food fraud is very
very now sometimes you see very
sophisticated issues it's very difficult
to detect because of young technologies
now allowed to deviate and it is big
concern for us we now have very
excellent laboratories at a joint
research center level but those labral
in in in some cases to detect only 40%
or 50% of enough of fraud and but it is
about laboratory but it's but it's but
then speaking about about possibilities
investigate to give information to have
to do to combine our forces all of these
prosecutors with customs officers then
of course we have enough instruments to
fight against against food fraud but
sometimes you can horse meat scandal was
it was very very very painful scandal
and it's you know one scandal can can
you know diminish trust in in in in in
food safety very much fear on your case
was it was it was about fraud but but
you know but but but in one hand we show
our effectiveness because in Soprano we
detected in whole European Union market
please build man you everyday produced
300 million eggs every day and our goal
was to add toad detect 60 million eggs
in such big amount of X in Europe and we
achieve in one week it means that we are
capable to address those issues but you
know but but but impact on people
perception is always great negative
negative issues and we have very high
attention and now we after fipronil
lessons now we we have more coordinated
systems between prosecutors all of
customs and food safety authorities and
now we established three links between
different IT stools which are used to
detect oxidation of course also you know
you can't avoid avoid new new new cases
yeah in dynamic but you know but those
smugglers are also very you know they
are very innovative
resist asking you a question about one
of the current crises among the many
that you've been talking about and that
is the brexit negotiation last week the
European Council President tusk was
quite concerned about the lack of
progress Theresa May went back to the UK
and the day after meeting with the rest
of the members of the European Council
said that we were at an impasse
and I'm curious what you think about the
likelihood of a deal a good deal good
deal for the EU and a good deal for the
UK as opposed to a no deal in which the
UK goes off the cliff edge next March
29th and I know that the the task force
the Commission task force of Monsieur
Barnier has been working very hard to
try to bring the sides together but we
now have a summit happening in in
October and October 18th the summit
tentatively planned in November another
summit in December but the article 50
clock is ticking and the time is running
out so what what do you what do you see
in terms of the state of play in the
brexit negotiation
I can't help asking since my name is
David Cameron also it's a very common
name yes unfortunately I am very
sensitive position and of course first
of all let me clear commission from the
beginning started to walk on all
possible scenario oh no that is our job
it's not to say oh I'm sorry if if
something No Deal
we are not prepared now we have if No
Deal we have action plan if another
version okay and now of course of course
you know very well that that about about
87 89 percent of all issues are solved
some of them are very technical and very
difficult but they are solved it means
that we are going into area where some
some difficulties of course you know
very well Irish borders it's very
complex but I think that now up to UK to
respond to our proposals I have no
chance to to go into details because I
am and rules and procedures but but it
is and I think for my point of view to
be better that leaders will be more
involved in homework and less in sending
different messages to society it will be
much more helpful because when some
leaders decided to send message one
response another commentators around and
political process is in different
directions of course we know that that
in that Teresa Mary had difficulties in
her own path
politically much more complicated
situation in this in conservative but
political but it's not up to us to add
to advice and of course and of course
also cut difficulties with this unionist
they are in college and it's up to them
to them to solve their homework because
some rational arguments are on the table
and my feeling is that my feeling is
that the clock is ticking and then clock
is ticking rational arguments can
prevail but from both sides we have a
lot of rational arguments how can
because we all know that no deal means
negative impact from both sides but
believe me four hundred fifty million
consumers and eighty million consumers a
little bit different one and of course
impact on you will be my less than
impact on UK because it's reality of
course we know very well that it will
have impact which one develop but now in
the temple are rational proposals from
both sides and teams are working day at
night and clock is ticking okay but but
that's that's right but because it's not
so it's not the game that we do not have
some solutions but now is also time to
consolidate political acceptance
especially in in UK but because of 27
are united we have now
now delicious but the visions I in in in
UK and it's up to them too
now to consolidate because they need
them to approve in in in Parliament
should consolidate situation if if they
can achieve such consolidation they I
think I think that that more or less
reasonable arguments on the table and we
and it is a lot of reservoir but but I
am open yes we have also scenario if if
it means that our obligation is to
immediately present mechanism which
should be valid in in in in in every
case time maybe for one more question
thank you thank you very much for
wonderful talking I'm a master student
of European and Russian studies here at
our University
I would like to it's possible okay
I would like to ask you about your
feeling of identity or sense of
belonging because I assumed that when
you were very little
you regarded you yourself as a Soviet or
at least your world was created by a
Soviet Union since it is the only
environment you were facing or you were
put on but now oh you came back to
Romania and you are working for European
Union so I am just curious that when do
you remember or when is there any
critical event to change your feeling of
identity or sense of belonging to when
did you start feeling you were European
not as obvious okay maybe because I
studied history and was very deeply
involved into ancient time of history
and it helped me to be European all my
life all my life I have no difference
you know for me it's a little bit
strange when they can make distance
second please explain to me what does it
mean to be European and to bility onion
latin alphabet the same religious
traditions more or less the same
education model as the same
possibilities to to see around around
you to play food is you are don't using
football here so sir
the same played basketball younger
generation knows very well same no
identity is very important issue if you
have you are never worried about your
identity because I am the trainer and I
never have doubt that I'm not not Union
but if you are playing game this
identities playing game oh no my
identity is the best in the world
ok then this is very dangerous because
if you are going into racism and into
experience of European European history
but it was National Socialism it was the
highest level of racism
Aryan that was terrible terrible
terrible bestial ISM but it was based on
feeling that I started to play game that
the Germans are superman's this is very
well that is a problem and of course to
be European now I am very proud that I
see millions of millions people who are
Italians Leoneans finns Estonians
and together the European European
Commission the full international in my
cabinet I have 16 people from 16 nations
and they are using their own language
they're using French German
English Spanish my team Italians the
tree onions and Romania please look
three teams are you all a European but
no one is in confrontation you know it's
a circle with a little bit artificial
retort oh it's now we have about sixty
million people who are working in
different countries in EU being Italian
working in in in in between or being the
trainer's working in United Kingdom it's
really and and such number is growing
because of a lot of different options
and of course also internet it's creates
a lot of possibilities tor to feel now I
always I always quote one old story from
meeting between Alexander the Great and
de Organa's the organiz was in sitting
on the on the on the beach and thinking
about and Alexander the Great came to
him and invited him to follow Alexander
in fighting with Perseus there Janice
told him you know I do not see need to
go together why because your
intervention require a lot of people
lives I am NOT not not ready to follow
you but Alexander told him look but we
will build new world you know going into
the organiz answer was very simple you
know I am building new world where I am
staying because where I'm staying
there is center of the world and I am
responsible to build something why why
you ask me to intervene something where
not nothing will be changed because I am
where I am and
click but I am cosmopolitan you know he
pronounces word cosmopolitan I am
citizen of the world and I am the tree
and I am Europeans the same for me it's
very simple that's wonderful story yeah
thank you very much I please join me in
thanking dr. Bettina under the sky teas
for spending this wonderful hour and a
half with us it's it's been it's been
fascinating
[Applause]
[Music]